la Maison Martin
valiamet au lendemain de la Première
Guerre mondiale la Réunion connaît une
période de prospérité de somptueuses
demeur créoles sont alors bâtis
notamment à Saint-André installé à
chamborne la famille Martin fait
construire une première maison au milieu
du 19e siècle mère de Saint-André le
docteur Léopold Martin en hérite au
décès de son père au milieu des années
20 il l'agrandit et l'embellit il ajoute
trois varangues et quatre pièces au
rez-de-chaussée et à l'étage quatre
chambres s'inspirant du styleard d'cho à
leur en VOG en Europe son propriéire or
la façade principale d'un beau window
couronné d'un
balvre tout n'est que raffinement
élégance dans cette belle demeure
entièrement construite en bois la grande
délicatesse des menuiseries et des
dentelles de bois mais aussi les courbes
du soubassement de la façade principale
qui se prolonge jusque dans le beau
window l'intérieur de cette grande
maison de 24 pièces est lui aussi
remarquable sa varongue principale est
surmonté d'une mézanine donnant sur la
mer situé à l'arrière de la maison la
salle à manger possède un plafond
rayonnant unique à la
Réunion un très beau décor de lambri
orne également tous les murs de cette
vaste pièce monument historique depuis
1983 cette maison est l'un des
chefdœuvre de l'architecture
réunionnaise vendue à la famille valiamé
après la mort du docteur Martin ce qui
lui vaut son nom composé elle appartient
à la commune de Saint-André depuis 1981
et accueille aujourd'hui l'Office de
Tourisme Intercommunal de
l'Est y